وابرز التطورات الميدانيه في القطاع في
الساعات الاخيره
الماضيه ابرز التطورات هو قصف اسرائيلي
مستمر ومتواصل على انحاء مختلفه من قطاع
غزه لكن ربما المنطقه الوسطى هي المنطقه
الاخيره التي بات الجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف
من غاراته على هذه المنطقه يكثف من قصفه
المدفعي لا سيما مخيم البريج ومخيم
المغازي وحتى ان سيارات الاسعاف لا تستطيع
باتت لا تستطيع الوصول الى المناطق التي
يستهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم البريش
لا سياما المناطق الشرقيه وهناك بحسب شهود
العيان الذين نزحوا من هذه المناطق ان عدد
من الشهداء ما زالوا على الارض ولم تستطع
سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليهم بسبب كثافه
النيران من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي لا سما
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تطلق
القذائف باتجاه تلك المناطق وباتت هذه
القذائف تصل الى مديات ابعد اي الى قلب
مخيم البريج في وسط قطاع غزه ايضا مخيم
المغازي شهد عده غارات اسرائيليه وايضا
قصف مدفعي عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
الاليات المر الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على الحدود الشرقيه
تقصد بعنف هذه المناطق وحتى ان بعض
القذائف وصلت الى مراكز الايواء في مخيم
البريج ومخيم المغازي وكان هناك عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى جراء هذا القصف المدفعي
ايضا مخيم النصيرات شهد قصفا مدفعيا وقصف
من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه كانت كان
هناك
استهداف لمنزل لعائله نصار في المخيم
الجديد في مخيم النصيرات كان هناك ايضا
استهداف لعائله لمنزل لعائله الحزقي في
مخيم النصيرات بجانب مسجد القسام وهو اكبر
المساجد في مخيم النصيرات وك نقل ايضا عدد
من الشهداء والجرحى من من هذين المنزلين
ونقلوا الى هنا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
واي ايضا الى مستشفى العوده في مخيم
النصيرات بالتالي المنطقه الوسطى باتت
تشهد كثافه ناريه اكثر من شهدناه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى
المناطق التي تشهد القصف المدفعي والقصف
العنيف من الطائرات ومن الدبابات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه كما يحدث في شرق مدينه رفح
كما يحدث في منطقه الفخاري وفي ش المناطق
الشرقيه لخان يونس جنوب القطاع هذه
المناطق التي ايضا هي محاصره ولا تستطيع
سي الاسعاف الوصول اليها ايضا القصف
المدفعي بات يصل الى وسط خانيونس وشهدنا
قصفا في حي الامل لمركز ومستشفى الامل
التابع للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني شهدنا
ايضا محيط مستشفى ناصر كان شهد قصفا من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
القصف في مدينه خانيونس بات ليس مركزا على
المناطق الشرقيه فحسب بل وسط مدينه خان
يونس باتت القذائف تصل اليه باتت المناطق
الماهوله والمناطق الخدمات كمحيط مستشفى
ناصر ايضا تشهد قصفا من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه مدينه غزه هي الاخرى تشهد
قصفا من الطائرات ومن المدفعيه حي
الشجاعيه ربما وحي التفاح هما الابرز في
هذا القصف الاسرائيلي العنيف ايضا بحسب
شهود العيان وفي ظل انقطاع بكل تاكيد
الاتصالات والانترنت في كافه محافظات قطاع
غزه فالمعلوم شحيحه وهذا يعيق ايضا سيارات
الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني من الوصول
بسبب عدم قدره السكان على ال الصول اليهم
والاتصال بهم وبالتالي من يصاب او يستشهد
فهو يبقى على الارض ينزف ولا تستطيع لا
يستطيع السكان نقله في كثير من الاحيان
بسبب ق القصف العنيف وايضا بسبب شح الوقود
وايضا بسبب عدم قدره سيارات الاسعاف على
الوصول بسبب انقطاع الاتصالات والانترنت
حسب شهود العيان فان في منطقه الكتيبه في
هناك منزل تم استهدافه ولم تستطع سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول اليه ايضا طواقم الدفاع
المدني لم تصل الى هذا المكان بسبب انقطاع
الاتصالات والانترنت وهناك عدد من
المفقودين والشهداء ما زالوا تحت الانقاض
ومحاولات جاده وحثيث من اجل اخراج بعض
الجثامين وانتشال الجثامين والبحث عن نجين
تحت هذه الانقاض بكل تاكيد منطقه جباليا
وشمال القطاع بيت لاهيه وبيت حنون ايضا
يتعرضون الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه ومن
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ولكن بكل
تاكيد بسبب انقطاع الاتصالات والانترنت
الاوضاع صعبه للغايه المعلومات شحيحه
للغايه من يستشهد لا نعرف ما طبيعه هذه
الاماكن التي تقصف ولا طبيعه الشهداء
والجرحى ولا حتى اسمائهم ولا الاماكن التي
قصفوا فيها بالتحديد هشام بشكل سريع هنا
مع بث كتائب القسام وغيرها من الفصائل
لمعارك واستهداف لقوات الاحتلال في الشمال
يعيدنا هذا الى التساؤل عن طبيعه
التصريحات التي كانت تخرج من الجيش
الاسرائيلي وي تقول انه يسيطر على مناطق
الشمال ه هل خارطه الاشتباكات ما تزال
فاعله في شمال القطاع
هج الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره في شمال
القطاع والفصائل الفلسطينيه لا سما كتائب
القسام سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي يعلنون ما بين الفينه
والاخرى عن عمليات ينفذونها باتجاه جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والقوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة لقذائف ياسين وما بين تفجير
العبوات وما بين عمليات قنص وعمليات حتى
التصوير تعني ان المقاتلين ذهبوا نفذوا
هذه العمليات ثم عادوا
وبالتالي المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت
موجوده في تلك المناطق تنفذ عمليات واصوات
الاشتباكات تسمع في كل المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي سواء في
منطقه جباليا التي تشهد ربما الاشتباكات
الاعنف حتى منطقه بيت حنون التي قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه قصفها ودمر فيها العديد من
المنازل وربما نشاهد الصور فان منطقه بيت
حنون مدمره عن بكره ابيها والناس والسكان
نزحوا من هذه المناطق منذ بدايه منذ اليوم
الاول من الحرب لا سما وانها منطقه حدوديه
تقع على الحدود الشرقيه والشماليه
وبالتالي هذه المنطقه ربما كانت اكثر
المناطق رخوه ولكن رغم كل ذلك
فالمقاومة ايه وتوثق عمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي تنفذ في تلك المناطق ايضا
حي الشجاعيه ومنطقه خانيونس وجحر الديك
وكل هذه المناطق نشاهد فيها الكثير من
الصور التي تثبت العمليات التي تنفذها
المقاومه فوت منغز مراس شكرا لك